the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the brand new
night pass Studios I am Ryan sickler
Ryan sickler.com Ryan sickler on all
your social media let me just say this
first yes we're in a new studio uh we're
just getting going here we'll perfect it
as we go you know it's not where I want
it to be yet there's a few little tweaks
we're gonna make but listen Perfection
is just another form of procrastination
we're not stopping down over here we're
rolling all right so support us
subscribe to that YouTube I'm telling
you it helps us get out there in the
algorithm so more people can find the
show
um go watch my special Lefty son it's on
my YouTube uh please support that I saw
Tyler the Creator the other day say he's
promoting stuff that's been out a year
old and I'm like yeah why don't we pump
our own stuff harder than that he's like
what's three months is nothing so he's
right go watch Lefty son on YouTube all
right
um the patreon listen if you gotta have
more I'm telling you right now you gotta
have the patreon it's five bucks a month
there's no other levels or anything like
that and it's the Honeydew with you all
and you all have the wildest stories
I've ever heard in my life every week it
is something I give it give it a try for
five bucks you don't just get one
episode you're getting the entire back
library or you're getting the Honeydew a
day early you're getting it ad free
you're getting it at no additional cost
it's worth every penny I promise you
it's worth that cup of coffee all right
and if you're looking for a new podcast
to listen to go listen to my old podcast
the crab Feast I'm gonna tell you right
now it is such an active show still that
library is going to do over a million
downloads this year that's how many
people are still listening there's a
community online for it it's got all the
people you know and love in podcasting
telling completely different stories so
go check that out it's a great podcast
my tour dates look we're going all the
way through 2024 we just added a bunch
for this year there's still more more
common so here's what we got August 11th
that is here in Los Angeles I will be at
Flappers Burbank get your tickets now
it's one show August 11th August 18th
and 19th I'll be down in Tampa Florida
Steve Simone will be working with me
can't wait to come down there and see
you all Tampa September 1st and 2nd
Springfield Missouri September 15th and
16th is Tulsa Oklahoma that was the one
that had to be rescheduled there it is I
promised you I was coming September 29th
and 30th Phoenix Arizona October 27th
and the 28th Salt Lake City Utah all
right now that's the biz you guys know
what we're doing over here we're
highlighting the low lights I always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers I'm very excited to have
this guest on here first guest in the
new studio ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Sam Talent welcome to the
Honeydew Sam what an honor what a lovely
thank you so much it's just so good to
be here and I want to apologize because
we got these lights set up and then your
crew had to spend about an hour and a
half half putting powder on my forehead
so that we wouldn't burn out the new
cameras it's my fault yeah you have this
like very highly skilled bunch of people
in here what if Sam was underneath some
kind of sheet yeah we'll get the lights
down what if he had a bigger hat yeah so
I apologize for my head being well it's
so big and wet don't you came straight
from the airport with luggage baby and
is it is yeah and then you got uh seated
right here to kick off the maiden voyage
in a new studio what an honor to be part
of this uh institution well storied show
I was a big crab Feast Guy where are you
really oh yeah of course oh yeah young
comic listening to people be uh very
vulnerable and be like Oh I'm also bad
yeah they're good stories yeah they were
great listen to Sam Town knows what he's
talking about go subscribe he's a very
active Community
um before we get into whatever we're
going to talk about today please plug
promote everything you'd like I have a
podcast called chubby Behemoth with my
friend Nathan Lund that you can listen
to wherever you get podcasts
um you can see me live when this comes
out I'll be in Australia hopefully those
are sold out already so I don't uh have
to never return to Australia and then
I'll be in uh I'll be in Tampa I'll be
at laugh Boston I'll be in Kansas City
Sam talent.com I am on the road every
weekend and I wrote a novel called
running the light that you can buy as
well but if you're a comedy fan you're
tired of hearing about that I've been
promoting it non-stop for two and a half
years all right yeah so
um we just met today we did yeah um our
good friend Cassie's been trying to
connect us for a while hey Cassie thank
you so much thank you so much and um I
want to get to know you first of all
because I ask everyone to give me a
little bit of what we're going to talk
about so I do know we're going to talk a
little bit about your mom but tell me
about yourself where are you from
originally where'd you grow up all that
stuff I'm from Eastern Colorado I'm from
Albert County Colorado a town of less
than a thousand called Elizabeth where I
played Sports year round and was very
actively engaged in a student council
the thespian Society I did everything
there your mom and dad together they
were together the whole time yeah yeah
and do you have siblings I have a
sibling yeah Sophie so
[Music]
her husband won't shut up
hahaha
she's very flexible I guess I don't know
uh no she's fun man she's just like
tough we just had my wife's graduation
ceremony for her she's done with
residency and we had that this weekend
and right around 1am everyone's like
well it's time to hit the old hay and my
sister's like we have to do shots out of
each other's mouths like we cannot stop
partying right now just because you guys
are blackout drunk and everyone wants to
leave so she's very good about keeping
uh the momentum going all right creating
momentum yeah even if there is no
momentum even if everyone's begging to
end things so yeah I love her I love my
dad love my Mom I had a very nice
upbringing all right very small town new
everybody
yeah did you excel at Sports in school
or I did excel at sports yeah I was an
All-State offensive lineman twice hell
yeah yeah I was gonna play football in
what position would you play I was a
right tackle for a left-handed
quarterback oh so you're The Blind Side
tackle yeah although we never threw the
ball we pretty much just played like uh
it was like a wing tea situation so I
don't think whatever the forward pass
was not allowed in the league we played
in from what I remember but yeah
um I play I wrestled you know I was
going to play college ball I hurt my
knees so I couldn't do that now where
are we going to play see you University
of Colorado yeah that was that would
that was that was the first uh whiff of
pain that I ever had but other than that
I have nothing to complain about started
doing stand-up when I was 18 moved to
Denver
here we are on the Honeydew yeah yeah
and a story you wanted to talk to is
about your mom's stroke we're going to
talk about yeah yeah so I've been
milking that for a while now how um tell
me about it how old was your mom and how
old were you when all this went down I
lived in Vegas my wife went to the first
two years of med school in Las Vegas
this was 2017.
my mother uh was the matriarch of our
family you know my dad lovable doofus uh
loved like mooning people at the post
office that kind of thing it was like a
fun guy a lot of like fireworks indoors
kind of guy you know
just a blast then my mom just like
pensively drinking a greyhound being
like these boys you know
um so she she was she was very heavily
uh for Hillary Clinton Hillary Rodham
Clinton
um and when Hillary Rodham Clinton lost
the election in 2017
to Donald Trump my mom's brain exploded
literally like they said Trump's uh
Trump's gonna win and then
her head popped and she hit the floor
and my dad was not there my dad was she
she worked in Denver so wait was it
literally at the time that time of day
was the announcement from what we can
tell my mom was texting my dad and my
Aunt Julie up until that being like this
this is [__] this looks bad what's going
on I can't believe this country
um and that as soon as Trump was elected
her phone went silent and my dad was
kind of like well this is weird maybe
she's just you know mourning her own way
um and then so he was at our house in
Elizabeth and my mom lived worked at the
Federal Reserve in Denver so it's like
an hour away and she got herself an
apartment down there so she didn't have
to commute and then my dad was like well
this is weird she's not responding so he
ended up driving out there and uh got
there probably around four or five in
the morning because he couldn't get a
hold of her and she was on the ground
you know in like full worm position
um and they had to you know knock down
the door of the fire department and yeah
it really rendered her uh
it's like a quarter of a woman so was
she really she was there that long alone
that long yeah and if your dad doesn't
go she probably dies yeah so there's
[Music]
um
I think she was born in 1953 and this
was in 2017 so 64 maybe yeah yeah
um and my dad he beat himself up because
he was like I should have been there I
should have gone there earlier but her
brain
I'm a very happy-go-lucky guy my dad's a
dingus my sister has more of my mom and
her but she's able to have fun but my
mom was like always so stressed she had
so much just the weight of her world the
world was on her shoulders you know
making sure my dad you know got sober
when I was 13. he was a bit of a booze
bag so she kept the whole thing afloat
um well let's hold on let's jump back
there why what made your dad finally get
sober when you were 13.
I think my mom gave him an ultimatum
we're uh my mom's from Cleveland my
dad's from rural Colorado so this level
of like openness is never really part of
our family vocabulary you know
emotionally
but I do remember that there was an
incident where like my dad uh got
[__] torn out the frame to act on a
nice like he got sober and then he found
a bottle of booze and my uh grandparents
basement he's like this is real good
whiskey it'd be a shame for it to go to
waste
pulled the cork
uh I think my sister found him down
there like you know totally dunzo and
then he I think took her on a ride
around uh the suburbs of Parker Colorado
and my mom was like
you just jeopardize your daughter's life
to kind of prove a point that you
weren't too drunk to drive you know that
classic move
and I think she was like look it's this
is for Real so
I remember my dad being a really fun
drunk I was gonna ask yeah was he and
abusive in any way or anything hell no
so he was so he was just making poor
decisions while he's drinking he was
privately blowing it yeah but to me he
was the funnest guy ever he was the guy
that all my friends wanted to come over
he was my football coach as a kid he was
the third base coach he always had a new
bit you know I remember my dad was the
king of the thumb gag and I remember
there was a kid named Cameron Rao God
bless him who told me when we graduated
high school he's like you know your dad
he was the best man you got to tell me
how's he [__] pull his thumb up and I
was like yeah I swear to God yeah yeah
and I was like dude Cameron I've known
you since kindergarten have you been
developmentally disabled this whole time
it's I can do it for you right now and
he was like ah his world shattered
around him you know
um so no he was the greatest he was he
was a hoot and a holler he was never
hung over around me I mean he would pick
us up from school with a tall boy he
would yeah but like that's what all the
dudes that I knew they were older like
men you know my my uncle
it was just part of the culture of
growing up uh in the middle of nowhere
so if
yeah he he never blew it to my knowledge
and sure there's all these like little
small things you think about where it's
like well
why was he asleep you know uh at my
sister's fifth grade or my fifth grade
graduation like why was my dad still
asleep you know it's like oh he was
hung over in three sheets
um so yeah no I don't ever have I don't
have any negative memories what it did
suck because it made my mom look like
the bad guy yeah because you know like
when your dad's like Hey we're gonna
you're gonna go to this pool hall that
has like an arcade machine here's a sock
full of quarters go crazy I'm gonna be
down the street at the bar with my
friends when your mom calls and she's
like he left you alone at the pool hall
you're not like yeah how dare he you're
like yeah he's the best
is the coolest yeah there's a guy here
who's giving me all the chocolate milk I
can drink like I'm having a blast you
know so when she shows you up crying and
ruins your fun
it uh it just happened oh yeah yeah that
kind of stuff happened
um it doesn't reflect negatively on your
dad it makes your mom look like a giant
wet blanket which was so unfair to her
and when does that hit you at what age
do you shift where you're like oh I see
Mom was just holding it together not
being a pain in the ass I mean you get
older and you get perspective and then
you have you know lunch with your mom
when you're 19 year old who's gonna go
feature on the road for the first time
and she has all these like very
legitimate concerns about like you're
driving to Gillette Wyoming for a
hundred dollars and you have to split
gas with the guy and this guy's like a
known like the headliner you know it's
like this guy is like a
known he's a he's a rode headliner in
the Rocky Mountain Time region so he's
got problems Rocky Mountain time oh the
Mountain Time Zone dude for stand-up
those people are monsters if you don't
leave Denver and your whole thing is
like I got the I got the Indian casinos
I got that run that's gonna put 1200
bucks in my pocket as a comic who's been
doing it for 20 years and so I'd have
these conversations with my mom or she
had all these like legitimate concerns
and then you could tell your dad and
he's like oh hell yeah dude you're
making it attaboy and then you're like
oh Mom's been right the whole time you
know about these like actual concerns
um so yeah I can't say that my dad was
ever a bad father uh what do you
remember about him sobering up like
did it this level of fun change did it
really well it was like a whole like
calamitous situation
my dad worked at the bank my mom worked
at the Federal Reserve they were both
Bank examiners when I was a kid and then
my dad made some like
one of his multiple shell organizations
uh and he started some business and this
dude named Bill huff and I'll say his
name because he [__] over our family
heavy he my dad gave him some money to
start this business and then the guy
bailed like it just ran away to what we
found out later to be Mexico
so my dad like finally had a little bit
of money and he was like this is going
to turn everything around he just took
all of it he never even did anything
didn't do a damn thing
so that rocked my dad sent him kind of
into a bit of a spiral and then he came
out of that sober and he's like I don't
want to work at the bank anymore I want
to be a teacher
so in that time my mom went back to
school to get her Masters in landscape
architecture which is a giant waste of
money okay yeah I was about to say
that's a I mean no offense that's a
thing I didn't even know that was a
thing yeah is that for companies like
Disneyland and stuff like that are we
talking about massive architecture for
landscaping like City buildings and
things I think my mom thought that she
was going to recreate the Luxembourg
Gardens in Paris but in uh Castle Rock
Colorado because I remember I thought my
mom my mom had this like very high
fluting idea of like you know like
people need Parks you know like that's a
big part of why Europe is so good
because all these like green spaces and
people can go and be outside and just be
like kind of Enchanted
and I would go to she went to the
University of Colorado Denver uh to get
her landscape architecture degree and I
remember sitting at all the uh drafting
tables there and I was just given all
these markers and I would just you know
ruin these like 12 markers like drawing
you know X-Men characters but my mom had
all these giant drawings of top-down uh
Topography of what she thought that a
good Park would look like you know the
trees here here's the pond all this
stuff so I saw this stuff that she
thought she was uh she was going to
change the world
she ended up doing like you know there's
enough trees in the parking lot at Park
Meadows Mall like she got a job with
Douglas County just going around and
kind of auditing that they had enough of
you know you know the boulevards had
grass on them there was the parking lots
had enough uh you know Lawns that were
big enough
so yeah she was totally just dejected by
what she thought was going to be this
cool creative Outlet as someone who my
mom was an amazing artist she loved to
read very funny and then
she worked at the banks forever and then
she was like no I hate this I'm not
being able to express myself and then
she didn't get to do that at all after
going to school
so anyway my dad
he ends up working at Walmarts
overnights as he gets his [__] together
unloading trucks and working in the
bakery so like fifth grade fourth grade
my dad just wasn't around as much
because he would be asleep during the
day and then at night he'd wake up and
go work this
terrible job just the soul-crushing job
so that he could you know continue to
support and everything while he wound up
getting his teaching license
um so yeah that was like and I there was
like this time in fifth grade I went to
school like 40 of the days that you were
supposed to go
um and I remember because I would fake
sick all the time because I didn't want
to go to school is that full [__]
gifted and talented thing where it's
like oh I wasn't being challenged so
school sucks
um like I started taking the SAT prep
when I was in like fourth fifth grade
did you really yeah holy [__] well it's
just like in this very small town you
know I had a very active mind I loved
reading I was always writing stuff and
they didn't know what to do with it so
they're like well I guess we'll just
teach him how to take the SATs like if
he's gonna you know hopefully go on to
bigger and better things we should just
put them in standardized testing did you
take them I took them I took them twice
a year from like fifth grade all the way
through what do you remember what you
got in fifth grade no I don't I don't
what was your highest ever so in the
SATs I don't know but so that was the
most [__] part was I studied for the
SATs and then in Colorado to go to state
schools you took the acts but the acts I
crushed I think I got in in language I
got like a 33 or a 34 out of what what
is it I think 36 and then I think I got
like a 29 in math in science but I was
terrible at that stuff
so anyways a long way to say that I
remember my dad picking me up from
school one day and he just woke up
having worked all night you know white
knuckling his sobriety trying to get his
[__] together and he was like I don't
know what's going on with you but this
whole fake and sick thing is is over we
got to figure this out and I just
started crying and I was like I just
never see you anymore man whenever I you
always pick me up and then he was quiet
the whole ride home not even any music
on my dad's a big music guy I remember
him not having any music on and me just
sitting next to him as he like gently
sobbed and that was one of them two
times I saw my dad cry one being when
his mom passed away
how which was first
uh his that my my grandmother passed
away after this after yeah yeah so this
is the first time you saw your dad ever
cry yeah and it was that like man crying
where it looks like you know you're
trying to fight off an aneurysm so
like you're just gonna like beat a heart
attack you know yeah through
perseverance
yeah you know how to take the wheel my
dad would do weird [__] man I remember
he would do these drills this is when he
was drinking so like at the end of
football practice uh we would pack up
all the pads and everything and then he
would uh be like all right so if we ever
have to make a getaway you're gonna have
to get in the moving car so then he
would just like drive through the Polo
Fields as I was running my little fat
body itself next to it like trying to
get in a moving vehicle he's like you
got it grab the door grab the door now
throw your body and head first don't put
your feet in don't you can't keep up you
got to put your body in and then me like
diving in and when you look at it
through the oh he was just wasted you're
like oh that was insane thing to teach
we used to hitchhike all the time when I
was a kid what why well he would have
all these like Volkswagen like buses or
like just like weird Volkswagen uh never
bugs but the you know the sedans and
he'd get him for like 400 I think he
would get them because he when he was
working at the bank this was such a
small town that when you couldn't pay
off your your mortgage you would get
paid and they would give pigs to the
bank or they would pay with like bales
of hay so I think certain
regulations yeah they gave an old car
and they would break down all the time
because I don't have any mechanical
knowledge neither is my father sorry
there's a lot of memories of like me and
my sister I remember my sister being
because when like when I when I was born
my dad quit to stay home and raise me
that was the thing so we took like three
four years off until I was in
kindergarten why dad and not mom did Mom
have the better more secure job yeah my
mom worked at the Federal Reserve so she
had a good thing going and my dad was
just working at Kiowa State Bank which
was the biggest bank in the incredibly
small agricultural town that I was from
and um so yeah it was just like my
sister my I didn't have I didn't wear
shoes to my knowledge until I went to
kindergarten we were to shoeless all the
time and my dad used to just tie my
sister's head off into a ponytail at the
side big whale spout and then just a
gigantic T-shirt with like a diaper
underneath it I just remember her
standing on the side of the street in
jelly sandals
um and us with our thumbs out and some
lady stopped to pick us up some like a
nice church-going woman and she's like
what is what are you doing and just gave
my dad this tongue lashing my dad's kind
of like you know we all got to help each
other his big thing was we're not
Farmers we have to help each other you
know because that taciturn nature of
farmers and uh and us like getting in
and her driving us like you know five
minutes and her just [__] reaming you
remember that yeah yeah and I was just
like you know what this lady sucks my
dad's cool yeah we were I think we were
literally going to sneak into the Pawnee
Hills Clubhouse pool I think that's why
we were up there yeah so it's like he
was trying to give us a good time his
car broke again we've hitchhiked a
million times is not a big deal you know
he's from my dad went to the same
he went to in Elizabeth the the middle
school that I went to was the school he
went to K through 12. so it's like he's
been here he knows everyone you're the
outsider lady Dave Talon hitchhikes I
knew that when I was like seven years
old I was like this is a way of life for
sure bro Dave Talon yeah
so like it sounds like I'm kind of
lambasting my father but no I loved like
I have no negative memories I remember
them fighting and I think that's why the
whole comedian thing came in because
like my dad and my mom would get in
arguments and I'd be like doing bits as
like a seven-year-old you know like
pants fall down bits like whoops going
on you know just please stop fighting
anything but this yeah so there was that
stuff but
no one ever hit me my dad would flick
the back of your ear that's how he got
your attention just one right to the
back of the ear which is
a very effective method it is yeah so
yeah man I don't I don't I wish I
if there was more trauma to mind from
that but it would just be Stolen Valor
you know stolen balance
it would just be hyperbolic for the sake
of uh creating drama and I didn't have
that my grandparents were there but you
never you never once you had
um the hindsight and obviously the
knowledge and the wisdom you never
looked back on your dad in a negative
way you just you never thought wow he
was drunk doing this stuff it was just
what was it for you no
um my dad was always there my dad
coached football and we dominated in
football he coached basketball he
coached baseball he was beloved by all
uh he always had a joke my dad and my
grandfather his father there's this
weird Phenomenon with the talent men
where you'll just be somewhere and
automatically you'll talk to someone
this happens to me on planes all the
time where after two minutes of
conversation they're telling you about
uh the worst thing that's ever happened
to you they're they're done yeah me too
yeah and it's just something that is a
phenomenon to us I remember my
grandfather we'd be at the at the
grocery store and he talked to someone
about like for like 20 minutes about
like their wife dying and I'd be like
Grandpa who was that and he'd be like I
have no idea
so my dad did that a lot he was always
there for people I'm that guy I I'll
still to this day I remember I was in
the Glendale Mall goddess was in the
late 90s I was with my girlfriend at the
time
and we were in like Gap or something and
there was a doorway to get in here the
big stores and you can go out here too
two ways to get in and we're near the
one of the entrances or exits and I see
this homeless guy walk into the other
one and he just makes eye contact with
me locks eyes and I said that guy's
gonna come and talk to me she's like how
do you know I go because this is what
happens to me and he went right by
everybody and came up and just started
talking to me just out here the other
day guy out comes over just starts
telling me his whole life story yeah I
get a the craziest one ever happened to
me was on a flight to Denver actually
and
um there were these two young boys that
sat next to me and they were really
young uh one might have been
maybe five and the other one might have
been like eight or nine they were
brothers and their mom had put them on a
plane to go see their dad so they're
sitting with me but they were you know
being uh taken care of by the airline
and uh the one just starts chatting me
up he's the older brother he's in the
middle the younger brother's on the
island he's already asleep and it's a
late night flight and they're talking to
me and he's going to meet his father
um who is now a woman wow and who's
married to a woman wow and this is his
first trip to go meet the man he knew
was his dad now as a woman and this
kid's telling me all about it and I'm
just looking at this kid and I'm just
like
I got I got nothing for you
earbuds in
you know it's rough out there for
everybody and I felt so because he was
confused and he's like do you think
they'll still like we'll still have a
Christmas I was like yeah you're gonna
have a Christmas who cares if you're
dead that's your mom the Christmas is
going to be so much better there's a lot
there's a bunch on the line you have two
moms dads don't do the buying no you got
two moms buying all your gifts kid you
leveled up you just won the lottery
yeah this is a dream boy all right and I
was like man and I'm thinking like this
poor kid
is tackling stuff that adults most
adults are never going to experience
like I'm not a licensed therapist in any
way and I'm just telling this kid like
you know stay positive and enjoy
Christmas it might be your mind I don't
know even how to say your dad may be
your mom now but your mom still loves
you you know I'm giving them all the
pineapple just sitting there like what
the [__] yeah yes yeah I get it non-stop
they just love to dump on me I mean but
that is that's even more peculiar
because it's a child that was so there
must be some kind of pheromone it has to
be on some kind of thing you think if
there's some level that we have
interesting because I mean I'm not
necessarily the most like open person
like when I'm out it's like I have
things to do I really value my time at
home but if someone does want to just I
used to take Greyhounds to gigs I was a
Megabus guy so you get trapped on those
things oh yeah those are full of people
that want to tell you their sorrows or
woes because hopefully when you get off
at the next Pit Stop you'll buy them
some Carl's Jr yeah if they just like
you know show you the [__] bag of
change that's gonna get them all the way
to Tucson you're like all right it's
four breakfast burritos here's ten
dollars yeah here you go yeah yeah
here's a Lucky Strike yeah I don't even
smoke here's a pack
yeah dude that [__] is bizarre and
there's a lot of men that I've talked to
that have that
um but it was so just pronounced with my
dad and my grandfather Yeah you weren't
talking so much please this is your
episode oh that's sweet you would see it
um you remember seeing that as a kid
people come up and talk to them as well
not just them telling you about it no I
remember it because I mean I spent so
much time with my dad because he you
know quit working for a while to raise
me and then my grandfather was like I
was always with Grandpa over talent was
the man and yeah I just remember being
out with them and just being like
bored that's why I remember because I'm
standing there with my hand on the
grocery cart being like can we please
move this along so I can go buy a new
copy of Jughead like I know something's
coming at the end of this uh that I'm
gonna get paid off so
yeah that that's and that's just it's
something in our blood I think
okay so back to your mom so your dad
drives out to check on your mom because
it's odd that obviously after all this
communication or phones now right or
it's she's not responsive and he finds
her curled up on the floor I think the
fire department all the fire department
yeah
okay and then and what's this so it's
all a blur dude I was in Vegas right how
old are you at the time I am this was
2017. so that was nine six years ago six
years ago so 30 okay I'm 30 years old
and I just had moved to Vegas about 18
months prior so my wife we got married
and then four days later we moved to Las
Vegas and I went from like being in
Denver where it was non-stop fun with my
friends living in an apartment building
where like five of the units were
occupied by my sister and my four best
friends like non-stop good time stage
time constantly kind of King [__] of
Denver at that moment you know
um to going to Vegas where it's like
comedy in Vegas is abysmal it's the
worst place in the world to do stand up
the people who go see comedy in Vegas do
not like creative comedy they want my
wife's [__] stinks here's how bad it
smells
I swear to God they want they want to
catchphrase I wrote this bit when I was
there yes phrase you're right [__] my
big old ass was the catchphrase bit that
I had and I would do it there and be
like my friends you know I would go do
it when I'd go on the road I was still
on the road a lot and it was kind of
like a post-modern thing like you know
they love Catchphrase Comedy you do a
terrible setup and then [__] my big old
ass so I thought it was kind of you know
I don't want to get too high fallouting
but definitely like a winking you know
like
your anti-comedy thing but I would do
that in Vegas
and people would be like but the third
time you say it [__] my big old ass they
love it they're like are you gonna sell
t-shirts after this I was about to say
yeah and then I would go to like these
kind of like alt you know bookstore
shows on the road back when I couldn't
move any tickets and those were great
shows I was glad to have them I'm not
besmirching them and I'd do it there and
they'd be like that's awesome man yeah
[__] those people that like that kind of
thing so that might have been the best
bit I ever wrote Because it worked for
everyone segor and I used to talk about
this all the time he used to and this is
way before he blew up or anything and he
was like Ryan I really feel like
if I create a character yeah I'll I'll
get there quicker than ever and we
talked about this character he was
talking about name rodeo and the
catchphrase was Hey Ho rodeo and he said
I said Tom if you do that yeah I promise
you
you're gonna hate your life sure shoot
right to the top oh yeah just the
merchandise sales alone
they're all saying it yeah like yeah 100
yeah this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp whether you're dealing with
decisions around career relationships or
anything else therapy helps you stay
connected to what you really want while
you navigate life so you can move
forward with confidence and excitement
trusting yourself to make decisions that
align with your values is like anything
the more you practice it the easier it
gets you know I love therapy here we're
big time on therapy we talk about mental
health and physical health emotional
health all of it therapy is a wonderful
thing I'm telling you if you're thinking
of starting therapy give better help a
try it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com honeydew today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew again
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew now let's get
back to the do yeah so like I would see
you know I would see and these I don't
you'd see Buffet Jackson Go on stage you
know and he would kill and you'd be like
well I'm gonna go up and do what I think
is funny and then not do well and you're
like what am I doing why am I here I had
a residency in Vegas that was the it was
a big deal it was on the Strip two weeks
at Planet Hollywood
and I was like this is a big deal like
I'm moving to town I got a residency
everything's gonna be okay I'll be able
to be in town for my wife while she's in
the first two years of medicine for four
years it must be four years of med
school which is a very harrowing time
for her
and I was just I bought I died
constantly and not in like the kind of
like you can save it or you're having
fun like literally you're supposed to do
20. I had a guy one time raise his hand
like three minutes into my set and he's
like excuse me and I was like yes sir
and he's like no more of you and I was
like what do you mean and he's like
you're ruining my wife's birthday I was
like it can't be that bad Spotlight onto
his wife weeping into her hands
only a few minutes shoulders bouncing
makeup I have no idea I don't know what
they thought they were going to see at
the you know Comics Cabaret Planet
Hollywood yeah we ended up being a
Latvian guy so I try to save it you know
after four more minutes but everyone
else is having fun right bone-chilling
silence earth-shattering silence
supposed to do 20 I do 12 and I'm
bringing on a you know a cabaret act she
has to come back out she has to come out
and do her thing but it's a Vegas show
so she knows she has exactly to this
moment to the second when she's coming
on stage so now it's just eight minutes
of me being like Tana the Tattooed Lady
everyone she'll be right out let's be a
little bit louder it was so bad and I
get off stage and I just called my wife
and I was like I think I need to go back
to college I don't think I can do this
anymore here that's why I started the
road even harder just so I could prove
that I wasn't terrible at comedy so
we're there and election night 2017 and
uh I'm going to Denver the next day I'm
going to fly to Denver to do comedy
Central's roast battle in Denver uh my
first big TV credit
uh and they're filming it at Comedy
Works my home Club so I wake up in the
morning I have an early flight anyway
and my dad a bunch of text messages call
me when you wake up I think he's you
know being weird about picking me up
from the airport and he's like hey man
your mom's in the hospital she had a
massive stroke it's very touch and go
when you arrive I just want to be honest
with you
hopefully she'll still be with us it was
that bad it's that bad so my wife calls
into school get her a plane ticket we go
to Denver fingers crossed uh you know I
go straight to the hospital my whole
family's there my mom
non-responsive can't talk massive like
huge huge brain injury and I hang out
with her all day and then that night I
have to go to Comedy Works with a bunch
of jokes I've never told before because
it's a roast I haven't worked these bits
out
and I just remember getting there and
Justine Moreno was a great lady from
Denver yeah known her forever she's with
nothing but good to me she's why I'm on
roast battle because she was like if
you're doing Denver you got to have Sam
so I just go up to her at the hotel and
I'm like she's like hey Sam how are you
and I'm like well just you know I just
want to let you know my mom a huge
stroke
I don't know if she's going to be alive
moment to moment
don't pull any punches you know and
she's like oh
I need to I need to do some stroke
material you know of course he's a comic
you know it's perfect it's what I needed
to hear
uh you know we do the show and then I go
right back to the hospital so anyway all
that said now I don't live in Denver
anymore and my wife is in med school and
this is hard and I need to be there for
her but also at my mom you know it's
just a weird thing to have to figure out
your priorities at that age like I love
you uh I want to build a life with you I
know you're doing something very brave
and difficult but I gotta be here I
gotta be with my mom
so there was all this just like back and
forth being in Denver going back home
taking care of her
so my wife the best Woman Saved My Life
in multiple ways uh she ended up
transferring which you don't transfer in
med school that's like an impossible
list oh is that right it's very
difficult to do
she transferred to a school uh an
osteopathic medicine school which was
about a half hour from where my parents
lived
so we moved back
and now there's this in this and we
moved back in May of the next year so
there's about you know seven eight
months where it's just this whole new
dynamic because my mom took care of
everyone my whole life she was the
person you called if you had any
difficulty you know you have to borrow
money you hit a mom you know don't worry
but dad's there but he's more of a
mascot you know he's a mask that sounds
shitty to say but like on the team that
is my parents my mom's George
Steinbrenner you know what I mean she
runs the operation yeah and dad he's
there to raise morale you know if you're
having a party yeah exactly yes my dad's
the Philly fanatic and my mom is trying
to build a [__] franchise you know
she wants to hang some she wants to hang
some pennies from the Raptors you know
and then there's so there's these weird
uh you know my sister's like you gotta
be home more there's just a lot of
pressures that are coming in from all
over so my wife transferred and then it
was just like okay my mom probably had
50 to 100 words after that you know
effectively wheelchair bound she could
walk with a cane and my mom who was the
most independent woman who who really
valued her autonomy is now like kind of
just beholden to
the patience of her family not that we
wouldn't give her everything but
you I remember my sister one time being
like Mom say my name and my mom could
say the name Julie because that was her
sister's name
so she would just be like
Julie and my sister being like say my
name mom
Julie Julie and then my mom starts
crying my sister starts crying
so there was just a horn you're just
like Julie [__] settle down over here
right well yeah yeah
hey throw her [__] bone feet all
right okay she's using a spoon yeah can
we count some of these small victories
no words to a hundred yeah Julie you're
Julie we're all Julie all right
everyone's Julie now it's a new world
there's one name it's Julie and it's
Dave all right yeah that's what we got
we got my dad she did have your dad she
remembers yeah did you remember her name
no I mean I don't think she I think she
could say Betsy did she remember yours
she knew she could write on it she
couldn't say it she couldn't say that
okay you know and then to see my mom who
had the most beautiful flowery cursive
script handwriting now having to write
and block letters just like she beat
herself up so much over the course
before until she passed like five years
later
um and it was just so difficult to see
my mom just like it's so pissed at
herself and then also she can no longer
travel by herself you know and my dad
who I just called the mascot got the
level of empathy in patience that he
showed stepping up completely to be her
caregiver and to be everything to her
you know he learned how to cook he
learned how to decorate he learned how
to uh you know paint uh the pottery you
know just like all the stuff that my mom
really liked he would do that for her so
he my dad in this whole thing we all
leveled up as far as like human beings
but good God was I'm so proud of my
father
because again it's great doofus you know
like honestly just like me incapable of
very mundane things but here he is with
my mom you know learning how to cook the
[__] quinoa you know learning how to
my dad at this point
20 years sober learning how to mix a a
greyhound exactly the way my mom liked
it it was insane dude it was insane to
see this guy who was just like a Good
Time Charlie end up being like a
Sanctified member of our family
um
and then just her like downfall we still
traveled with her but it was we used to
go we go to New Orleans every year as a
family and my mom would just in the
morning we'd be hungover she'd wake up
go about her day come home we'd get
lunch
and now you know having to
you know not get wasted the night before
because Mom wants to go to the French
market so it's like okay we're all gonna
wake up at eight now the entire Dynamic
changed sure
um well good I mean that you guys did
that we did everything
yes right you could have gone and been
just like no right
um so was she in a wheelchair the entire
time I mean she could putter around the
house you know and when when like when
it mattered my mom would she would dress
up you know put on her furs
she'd have that cane I remember I had a
special come out
sorry
um
there's a special I did called waiting
for death to claim us and it it's on
Amazon for free
what a just ghoulish time for a plug
um
I mean let's check that special oh my
God
you ever catch yourself like remembering
where you are and you're like oh yeah
hopefully I get some more eyes on this
thing
oh my God God damn it
um [__] so anyway we debuted the special
uh we we put it out uh in a movie
theater in Denver oh that's nice it was
nice we did it in Fort Collins where I
live now and in in Denver Colorado
um and my mom came
and she watched it she walked in you
know with her cane all the way from the
front door she didn't want she didn't
even want my dad to park in the handicap
spot so I meet her out there in the
parking lot and I walk her in you know
and everyone my friends uh who've been
there since day one you know they come
up and they try and talk to her and she
just
good to see you you know like she didn't
say that is this the first time she's
gonna see you do stand up oh my mom was
there day one okay good my mom and my
dad so she wants this thing she's ready
for this she's been there since day one
this is your special dude
huh
anyway well I'll tell you this in a
second yes my mom was very proud of me
um and she was there you know she saw me
in Casper Wyoming she saw me in Kearney
Nebraska like she would drive to these
terrible shows and see me eat [__] in
front of people while they didn't turn
off the Corn Huskers game right you know
like she saw all the very bad things now
the special's coming out and comedy
Dynamics is putting it out you know for
whatever relationship I have with them
it was a big deal to my mom so she comes
in she watches it and at the end of the
night everyone's like hey what are you
doing and I'm just like sitting with my
mom and it's like I have to sit with my
mom is what I'm gonna do right now and
then when you guys all clear out of here
my mom's gonna take that long walk back
to the car so I walk her out I put her
in the car and then uh
she died that night no yeah I wouldn't
expect you to say that yeah my mom
passed away that night of a massive like
hard thing uh the night
did you drop her off I took her to the
car with my dad oh so you just walked
her walked into the car okay and then
you know because we're gonna go out then
we're celebrating and she's gonna go
home and who called you to tell you uh
my dad
it's actually yeah my dad drives up so
this was actually
yeah I'm in Fort Collins where my wife's
in residency and then um I there's a
knock at the door it's six a.m and I
assumed that my mom had just kind of
been like hey Dave I love you you got to
get out of the [__] house because
that would happen he would he she would
stay with my aunt he would come stay
with us just because he's they're on top
of each other right non-stop because she
needs him she needs someone to walk her
to the bathroom she needs someone to
make all of her meals you know just the
reality of the situation
and he shows up and uh I'm at the top of
the stairs and my dad comes in he knows
where the key is he comes in and he says
hey buddy I said what's up dude and he
says well
your mom died
and
you know you okay and right away I turn
in my mom's son I'm like okay I need to
pack a bag we need to go tell Sophie we
have to go tell Aunt Julie these are the
things we have to check off the list not
your mom died you know it's more like
okay and you know what my mom God bless
her
we would sit because my sister couldn't
deal with her emotional load her being
honest about her Calamity so
um
I remember my mom sitting with me once
on a patio somewhere and she was like
you know me better me
me when I was like Mom it wouldn't be
better if you were dead I'm glad you're
alive I know [__] sucks for you and I
could talk to her this way because like
we were like that so can I ask you real
quick yeah interrupt but she does
understand you when you talk to her she
just can't communicate back is she
comprehending the way you're speaking to
her like I can't remember the clinical
term I think it's synthesesia where she
can take she can hear you physically the
ears work but as far as processing it
every time it doesn't work every time
not every time no okay so there would be
things where you kind of had to explain
things more to her dumb it down a little
bit but yeah I'd say that as far as like
engage in a conversation she's 75 there
you know he's had to slow it down she
started counting airplanes man that was
the weirdest [__] thing just watching
him go buying she would when I'd come
out and I'd see her the first thing she
would tell me would be like
seven planes today
it's like okay and I guess when your
life becomes very small after being very
big
that's something that you can keep track
of you know what I mean that's
interesting seven airplanes today
so my dad tells me my mom's dead and
then my wife wakes up she starts crying
immediately they were Incredibly Close
because she altered her life path to
make sure that we were there for my mom
um and
my dad's standing over the sink with me
he's drinking water you know it's a
two-hour drive from where he was and he
says yeah she's
we made it
we made it 47 years and then she broke
her promise and I said dad what do you
mean he said we made it 47 years we're
supposed to make it 50 and then double
suicide
it's my dad the third sentence after my
your mom died we have to go tell your
sister
double suicide and I could see it in his
face that he thought it up on the drive
yeah yeah this is gonna be good this is
gonna be big
yes yes I just remember I mean before I
cried at all I'm laughing with my dad
over the sink
um and then we have to go if you tell
everyone my sister totally loses it you
know because
people experience things differently
it's totally fine and then that night we
go to my Aunt Julie's uh and we stay
there as a family we end up being
together for like a month between my
Aunt Julie and my house in Fort Collins
and I remember being up really late and
my wife being like because we you know
everyone just started drinking that's my
Uncle Tom my aunt you know Michael Tom's
known my mom longer than my dad it's all
and we've all been kind of expecting
this to happen you know what I mean like
she her faculties are declining
um
her test she's not drinking water my mom
would not drink water so she would just
have like kidney stones you know just
like all the time her urine is the color
of this table and my wife's a doctor at
this point so she like kind of knows
what's going on you know it's just like
okay if your mom's only drinking Mojitos
she would bring in her own Mojitos to a
bar
you know really yeah yeah because I mean
what's she have now not that she became
like this like awful drunk but she just
like she was medicating herself you know
and hey I get it no one's mad at you mom
you know so anyway
it was it was it was falling off you
know
um and
uh so I'm there that night and like I
don't write jokes well
um I like to improvise I even have an
idea you hammer it out on stage you know
after four weekends you got five to ten
minutes that's how but anyway I was just
like my wife wakes up and she's like
what are you doing and I was like I'm
just writing some stuff about my mom
um and that those jokes I end up just
trying I don't know getting the stuff
out that ended up being like this 20
minute set that I would do in front of
Tim Dillon when I was opening for him uh
in these big theaters and it was just
such a relief but I remember the big
thing being like
that weekend was the high plains Comedy
Festival The Comedy Festival in Denver
and I remember them being like hey man
we love you if you can't do it we get it
don't worry I was like I think I'm gonna
do stand up you know it's like this is
my favorite weekend of the year I
remember going on stage right before Amy
Miller God bless her love Amy love Amy
Miller long time friend of me and my
family and uh it was the first I haven't
told anyone I didn't I didn't want to be
the guy at the barbecue for the festival
being like hey you know my mom died no
so I go on stage and uh some some very
close people know David Bowie knew
Nathan Lund knew because bory's family
he's the voice of Comedy Central now oh
okay and we went from we met it we met
he went to my High School freshman year
and we became best friends he was like a
second son to my parents and then he
ended up doing stand up independently in
San Francisco he has a great career
um and I remember we went to my sister
and then he lives in Denver now we drove
to her to him and we all show up and
we're like hey David we gotta tell you
my mom died and he's sitting it's very
early he's sitting at his desk and
starts crying when he looks up and he
says
I really wish I wasn't wearing this
shirt
and we're like what and we look at it
and it's two huge white asses pointed at
the White House and it says uh twerk
2024. another big laugh you know
but I remember I do this set that
arguably the best I've ever been at
stand up in front of everyone and it's
it's very heartfelt and sweet and fresh
and then I remember all my friends are
washing the side of the stage and I was
like and you know this is pretty heavy
but if my mom could see it right now I
know she would say at least he's not
doing crowd work
and that's when my friends all started
crying because they know she would come
and see me at Comedy Works you know
featuring headlining and she'd be like
can't you just write a joke like what
are you doing you know that guy had a
cool hat on you're gonna talk to it for
10 minutes about his hat write a joke
Sam this isn't sustainable and then I
got off stage and I went and I just held
my friends in the middle of a green room
at a Comedy Festival and then Amy Miller
goes up and he's she's like here she
just goes on stage she's like what the
[__] what are we supposed to do yeah
he's your he's your hero he's from here
his mom's dead how many of you know how
many of you knew Sam's mom there's like
30 hands she's like oh my God I wish I
was dead you know so God bless her she
persevered but um yeah man it was it was
just it kind of teaches you and then I
couldn't smoke weed anymore
because I started having panic attacks
because I realized the Frailty of Life
listen as a Avid smoker yeah anytime I'm
at my lowest I can't either yeah it
makes me Focus so well which is why I
like using it that even during the bad
times I start focusing on those and then
future tripping on then I'm like oh my
God I can't smoke marijuana yeah I gotta
put this [__] down and I mean it Define
me from 14 all the way through 14. I was
smoking weed early man I mean I was
doing LSD at 13. I just went crap
accidentally when I was 13. these are
all my favorites The Accidental drugs
yeah well it was just because I I played
drums and I was the only drummer in my
very small town so there was older boys
and they had a band a very bad like corn
cover band effectively but they needed a
drummer and they were like the cool bad
kids you know Reed Barry and Jordan
Berry I remember being at a sleepover at
their house one day the berry boys the
berry boys them Berry boys
they're nothing but trouble it sounds
like it did you see them Berry boys in
the graveyard you let them do whatever
they're doing all right if Reid buries
in the cemetery you just keep on driving
all right because it is not good
but my dad was friends my dad was
friends with their parents so he knew
they were good kids they just like
smoked cigarettes and you know grave
Robert or whatever grave wrong yeah so
um yeah they were passing around a pipe
and I hit it because I was I'm not gonna
be a baby here and I hit it and it ended
up being crack cocaine yeah
good guys they've turned it around I
love them they're good men you know
I was a little fat kid and there was
this kid there named Dan Setter and he
had beef with a kid named [__] who was
another big fat guy but he was all on
crack and he thought that [__] was
sitting in the corner and he came over
and he had half a pair of scissors in
his Poncho he had a drug rug on and he
pulled him out and he's like [__] we're
settling this right now ah I'm a child
then it's me Sam Talent Dan having to
talk him off that ledge he died in a car
crash
um he did not turn around he did not God
bless him very funny very you know kind
of like a kind of anyway I don't need to
talk about Dan Setter uh but yeah so um
the weed thing I just realized kind of
like and I would have like uh I would
have the panic attacks manifested as
full-scale like heart attack symptoms
and I just remember like and I learned
how to do stand up Stone to the Bone you
know I got paid for some of the first
biggest shows I ever did in Colorado in
like you know a trash bag full of weed
like weed was the coolest I miss smoking
weed but I couldn't smoke anymore just
because
um I would start thinking about just
like how my mom healthy woman good blood
uh you know on the right medicine and
her brain just popped randomly and I was
like well [__] that's where this is all
going for everyone
um so yeah I missed it I can eat an
edible here there nowadays but if you
drink yeah but not like I used to on the
road man
it was it was bad I mean not like not
like the shows were bad but it was like
okay I'm in Chattanooga it'll kill you
it's if
there's beers and [__] right in the mini
fridge here there's anything you want to
order the food is all garbage you know
like it's not sleep is bad sleep's
terrible you're in different time zones
you don't know what the [__] going on
sometimes it's it's not a healthy
lifestyle yeah I was never trying to
take walks like we're trying to do
something out there and at least stretch
your legs or do something hit the little
gym at the hotel yeah thing to to keep
the machine in motion oh for sure I
remember I was I had I did something at
the Ohio State University uh because I
wrote this book about a [__] road dog
comic who just you know ever it was it
was very well received running the light
you can buy it at samtel.com there's an
audiobook if you're [__] stupid
a bunch of comics read it you can hear
Bert Kreischer try to read
um but uh so does he do it he reads it
he read the first chapter yeah yeah and
wanted the plays for the first chapter
set is to come carry New Mexico and him
trying to figure that word out live was
just a Transcendent moment for my audio
team yeah
um but anyway now it's like okay
um there's a Botanical Garden so I did
Ohio State and then Shane Gillis was in
town and I was like hey man uh you're
the funny bone what are you doing
tomorrow I'll come down he's like come
to a set I was like I'm gonna go to the
botanical gardens because botanical
gardens in Columbus Ohio are some of the
best in the United States oh is that
right yeah I know that it's amazing yeah
and I hit up Shane and I was like I'm
going to the gardens and he was just
like that's the gayest thing I've ever
heard
I was like okay you want to just [__]
be in your hotel room mired in your
hangover that's fine I have to go do
stuff you know because I've been on the
road so I was in bands first and then I
was in comedy and it's just like
and I don't know if you have this thing
because you don't drink right yeah yeah
so not I I listen yeah prior to all this
health stuff I I'd have a beer here and
there and now I don't even do that yeah
which is just cannabis and just shrooms
that's great those are what the surgeons
told me I'm allowed to have and they
said no those will never hurt you yeah
it's a great I don't need anything
pharmacist I'm not into pills never
thank God because I know I would be
addicted like everyone else I'm not a
big drinker I'm not into any of the hard
drugs none of that stuff no it's just
cannabis and I I don't even like the
infused stuff yeah you know I just want
plant and I mean flour and shrooms I
think they're nice and joint on like a
on a balcony while the Sun goes now or
you know what I miss is smoking weed and
going on a bike ride
because that makes it just mystical yeah
you know or a hike I love that yeah I
mean sure yeah
I'll work each their own you know
uh but
um yeah the weed thing Man it because I
had to re-learn how to do stand-up
because I was just stoned from you know
when I first stepped on stage at 18 all
the way until then yeah my thing now is
like when you go on the road uh you have
all these friends and it's a funny the
best part of being a comedian is
everyone who knows the funniest person
in that City so it's like okay you're in
Cincinnati then you're in Louisville
then you're in Indianapolis Thursday you
show up your boys you're gonna see once
a year they want to go out and have a
night with you and then that turns into
the next day you're hungover and then
you're on you know you're driving to
[__] Indianapolis and your friends
are there and you gotta have a couple
just because you feel like [__] and then
Saturday the show suffers so I've
definitely toned it down you know
because now I've worked so hard I don't
want to [__] [__] the bed now you
know because I can finally move a couple
units here and there but yeah boozing
was
it was just I would go out for like five
weeks and come home with like 400 and
I'd be like this is good not cheap
either yeah it's not cheap but it's also
like I'm doing this I'm getting good at
stand up and this is I guess just part
of the cost the self-flagellation that
you have to do tell me about your dad
now he's still alive right thriving dude
so is he single did he ever uh you know
date like do you talk to him about your
mom at all and if so what do you talk
about yeah I talk I mean my dad is
around all the time now I see more of my
dad now than I ever did as an adult
because now it's like when me and my
wife go on vacuum like we went to
Ecuador for all of May so she could do
immersive Spanish medicine and I wanted
to go down there and learn Spanish
better and work on my book and we had
this weird conversation where it's like
should we invite dad and she's like yeah
why not so now he's just in Rio bomba
Ecuador while we're there and we go hang
out with him and stuff so he's around
all the time
and um
yeah so my dad
uh you know
he's he's a handsome old man and I think
that he's he goes to these grief groups
you know I always joke about him just
like you know cleaning up 13 stepping
women whose you know husbands just went
in the grave
he doesn't do that you know
the body's cool yeah a little bit no so
I don't think that I know that he's he's
uh he's going on like you know Day dates
with a woman now and I remember that's
nice he goes to grief groups oh yeah he
still misses your mom it still bothers
him well I think he kills these grief
groups because he was in AAA you know
first so he knows how to talk in front
of a crowd he's good in front of a crowd
he's funny dude my dad this [__]
at my mom's funeral
I'm doing time I'm not doing time
oh [__] I got the lights
where's the lineup so I'm go I'm going
last at the funeral you're closing I'm
closing it down all right what the worst
booking ever
so I'm going last and my dad's like I
was like Dad you need to go last like
what are you talking about she's your
wife of 40 plus years and he's like no
just you close it down buddy you know
you're gonna be do great my dad did 50
minutes 50 did 50 minutes and at no
point was it like hey like this guy it
was tears it was him taking long pauses
when he needed to
I was just like dude you you your kid
and then all of a sudden you're an adult
and you had a dad and now you've got
kind of like uh you I I always admired
my dad but now like I really put him on
this pedestal and I'm so proud of him
um and now he's just around you know and
uh yeah and real in Ecuador I was like
that I'm not gonna be mad at you if you
have a girlfriend I'll be mad at you if
you don't tell me and he's like well I
should probably tell you something then
and uh I don't want to say it's a
girlfriend I want to put any pressure
he's going to listen to this I don't
want to put any pressure on him I'm just
I want him to be happy I don't want him
to be alone do whatever you want to do
Dad yeah we're all for it it's his life
and also he was there it wasn't like my
mom had her stroke and he was like I'm
gonna be at the pool hall he was like
there constantly so now dude in your you
know going into your 70s please get it
in pop all right do you um do you do
anything in your stand up or anything to
uh honor or remember your mom I had that
20 to 25 I did with Tim and we did like
four different or three different
continents and I did it every night you
know and it was just so it was it was I
so I did that but then it kind of felt
weird after I got done
to like I felt like I was like kind of
like I don't want to be vulgar like
humping my Mom's memory for like you
know like mining that for 25 minutes and
when I'm headlining it's improvising
it's silly it's not at all uh profound
in any way I don't want anyone thinking
or like ruminating when I'm on stage I
want them to be throwing up or mad you
know I don't I want them laughing or I
want them to be like what's going on up
there like Harlan Williams is a hero
yeah Rory Scoville when you watch those
guys you don't leave there being like
remember that remember that thing you
said about bananas and you're like I
don't know why that was so funny but in
the moment it was the best thing you've
ever heard so yeah so I had I had 25
minutes and I was proud of it and then I
just was like I gotta stop doing this it
feels weird
it didn't feel cathartic it didn't oh it
did in the time but then then after you
know a year goes by a year and a half
you're like I don't how I'm how I felt
when I wrote this in my aunt's guest
room uh is not true anymore right so now
I'm having like kind of like contrive
these emotions on not that I was like
weeping on stage but like the pauses
were like
I don't believe in this anymore you know
I've I've not that I've moved on I think
about my mom all the time whenever I
smell lilac you know whenever I hear the
name David Sedaris it's like all these
things that she gave me as a mother
whenever I travel my mom you know we
didn't have a lot of money because my
dad was figuring it out but she still
took us on vacation twice a year like
Bar Harbor Maine you know to Anna Maria
Island Florida all these places I'd
never heard of and that's when I was
like well man
um
you know what's [__] dude
uh for Christmas the year before she
passed away I got her and my dad tickets
to Paris nice yeah because she hadn't
been outside of this the states besides
like Mexico or Canada since her stroke
and I was like you gotta go you guys
gotta figure out how to do this because
I you know you figure she's gonna be
around forever you know and then uh
I didn't get the refund on those tickets
you know we couldn't
couldn't get the money back they didn't
let you get extended extend credit or
something about on a bereavement
yeah you know what was weird that's some
credits you could have used for the road
right you know what uh and also like
when she passed I never ever considered
like am I gonna get any money but I the
only the worst
when I went full Reed Barry in the
graveyard when I was like
hey Dad who's gonna get all these United
miles you can transfer those he's like I
think I'll hold on to him and I was like
okay you definitely need those I
couldn't upgrade all the time because my
mom flew for the Federal Reserve all the
time so
those miles they're just languishing
right now
you could be killing them out there oh
yeah I'm just waiting for upgrades like
an idiot no let me use these miles
dude thank you very much for coming on
and talking about this for real yeah I
feel like I talked too much I'm sorry so
your episode's what this is thanks uh
but before we end uh something I always
ask our guests when their first time
here is advice to give to their uh 16
year old self so after everything we've
talked about what do you think you would
tell 16 year old Sam Talent now is this
with am I the 36 year old man that sits
before you that has your wisdom and your
hindsight you can go back to your 16
year old self and give yourself a heads
up what would you like to say
um I would just say that
you should
in your 20s you're going to uh have
Regional success in Denver early
uh if you do stand up
uh and maybe don't spend every day uh
waiting to go on stage for 10 minutes
just sitting in a cloudy pot filled room
with uh women who either don't love you
as much as you love them or deadbeats
who can get eighths of weed for twenty
dollars you know that's great [__]
advice actually yeah it really is
because I do want him to make all those
same mistakes I wanted to get his heart
broken like maybe just be more aware of
the fact that like just because you love
someone a lot doesn't mean that they're
ever going to reciprocate that
um and uh just get outside more man you
know you gain some weight you go from a
stud you a D1 Prospect to uh you know is
stepping on the scale and in your wife's
uh medical clinic and her going what you
know yeah so just watch out for that you
know if you're gonna drink maybe don't
drink 15 beers maybe be a cocktail guy
yeah that's great you know
um and also travel more earlier go
outside of the United States earlier
because you really really think that
you're like this cultured like you know
uh man of the world but you were afraid
to go to anywhere outside of the states
because you didn't think that they would
be nice to you and also quit worrying
about people being mad at you
that's a big thing yeah yeah there's so
much my life defined by like I don't
want anyone to be mad at me yeah oh okay
okay yeah go for you yeah
um thank you again I really appreciate
you dude thank you man for real yeah I
really appreciate you having please plug
and promote everything one more time
yeah when this comes out I'll be in
Australia so come to those shows and
then um Sam talent.com I'm in every city
in America all the way through 2024
uh if you if you're listening to this in
Eastern Europe or Scandinavia I'll be
there in November
um I'm obsessed with doing stand-up
outside of the states right now it's so
much fun
um and uh follow at Sam town on
Instagram and check out Sam talent.com
with two else to see my dates this is my
podcast I went on Rogan I didn't plug my
podcast
bro chubby Behemoth it's funny listen to
it that's all I gotta say there's
nothing profound or insightful like this
one but if you want to hear about my
friend Nathan Lund uh being shut down at
a Burger King window for trying to order
10 Whoppers at midnight that's the Pod
for you
so chubby Behemoth listen to that all
right man thank you very much thank you
dude uh come see me on tour get all your
tickets at ryansickler.com and we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
yeah